nächster Redner ist Wolfgang Kubicki für
die Gruppe Kubicki und andere
50 Personen in seiner Gruppe und die
sind der Meinung dass impfen für den
Einzelnen sehr gut ist aber der Staat
das nicht zwangsweise anordnen kann und
sollen die liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ist natürlich schwer nach einem
solchen Debattenbeitrag darauf nicht
einzugehen aber die zeiterlaubnis mir
leider nicht denn ich bin auf drei
Minuten begrenzt wir können das an
anderer Stelle machen
ich kann gut nachvollziehen Herr Kollege
Sorge ich kann gut nachvollziehen dass
Emotionen bei diesem Thema hochgehen
gleichzeitig müssen wir aber aufpassen
dass im Eifer das Gefechts nicht
Argumente benutzt werden die weniger auf
Evidenz zurückzuführen sind als auf den
unbedingten Willen die eigene Position
durchzusetzen
abseits von politischen Bewertungsfragen
müssen wir im parlamentarische Prozess
dafür sorgen falsche Begründungen als
solche zu identifizieren und das
Argumente aus der Debatte herauszunehmen
und deshalb sollten wir mit Blick auf
die Anhörung und Gesundheitsausschuss
folgende Punkte festhalten eine
herdenimmunität wird durch die Impfung
nicht erreicht eine deutlich gefährliche
regierungsvariante im kommenden Herbst
ist nicht das wahrscheinlichste Szenario
ungeimpfte sind nicht schuld daran dass
ich andere Menschen infizieren
wir hatten keine Überlastung das
Gesundheitssystems und werden
voraussichtlich auch keine bekommen
die Einführung einer allgemeinen
Impfpflicht mit einem nur bedingt
zugelassenen Impfstoff ist
verfassungsrechtlich ohnehin ein Problem
Impfungen dienen dem Selbstschutz und
nicht im fremdschutz wenn wir uns auf
diese Punkte verständigen können darf es
aus verfassungsrechtlichen Gründen keine
Impfpflicht geben es ist nämlich nicht
die Aufgabe des Staates erwachsenen
Menschen gegen ihren Willen zum
Selbstschutz zu zwingen
dieses Haus hat eine Vorbildfunktion für
die Debattenkultur in unserem Land
deshalb darf es nicht darum gehen am
Ende eine Abstimmung als vermeintliche
Sieger oder Verlierer dazu stehen ist
muss uns darum gehen am Ende die
rechtlich und gesundheitspolitisch beste
so wie die gesellschaftlich verträgt
diese Lösung gefunden zu haben und hier
können die Menschen erwarten das neue
Erkenntnis auch zu einer Revision der
alten Positionen führen wenn die data
Variante viel in diesem Hause zum
Umdenken in Sachen impfpflich gebracht
hat dann muss das Auftreten der milderen
ommikonvariante konsequenterweise
ebenfalls zu einem Umdenken führt
die Menschen
können nachvollziehen dass bei einer
verschärftende Situation auch schärfere
politische Maßnahmen gefordert werden
wenn diese schärferen Maßnahmen aber
auch gefordert werden obwohl die
Situation sich entspannt hat dann stellt
sich die Frage ob es wirklich noch eine
sachgerechte politische Lösung oder eher
darum geht die politische Deutungshoheit
zu behalten liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
der Ethiker auf den sie ja so viel immer
wieder berufen und ich empfehle ich
empfehle die 161 Seiten des integrats
mal zu lesen der integrat hat in dieser
Woche eine bemerkenswerte Stellungnahme
zur vergangenen und künftigen
Auseinandersetzungen mit der
corona-pandemie abgegeben er formulierte
unter anderem und ich zitiere wenn die
von einer pandemisch auftretenden
Infektionskrankheit ausgehenden
gesundheitlichen Risiken durch Impfungen
Medikation Immunisierung durch
vorausgegangene Infektionen oder auch in
Folge der Verbreitung neuer
Virusvarianten mit höherer Infektiosität
aber geringerer patogenität unterhalb
dessen liegen was die Gesellschaft im
Hinblick auf andere Viruserkrankungen
hinzunehmen bereit ist lassen sich
schwerwiegende freiheitseingriffe nicht
mehr rechtfertigen Zitat Ende
deshalb frau Präsidentin war ein letzter
Satz deshalb ist eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht ob ab 18 oder 60 wieder
rechtlich noch gesellschaftspolitisch zu
rechtfertigen ich danke für die
Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]